breaking forth walls for aliens
foregoing science for love and reality
versus illusion these Bargain Basement
endings left many audiences feeling
shortchanged but hey at least we got to
see Batman fake his own death so there's
that
directors have imagined the end of the
world a thousand times over but
audiences keep coming back for more
apocalyptic Thrillers a doomsday film
Done Right is always both thrilling and
thought provoking encouraging viewers to
wonder what these visions of the future
reveal about the state of humanity today
of course an apocalyptic movie that ends
on a sour note just feels like a shoddy
attempt at indulging in spectacle
without offering anything of substance
that's exactly where director Alex
proyas's 2009 film knowing Falls flat a
young boy named Caleb discovers a page
full of mysterious numbers during a
school event his astrophysicist Father
John discovers that they represent the
dates of big disasters and that the
biggest disaster of all a massive solar
flare will happen in mere days just
before life on our planet is decimated a
mysterious spaceship descends from the
heavens with alien strangers beckoning
Caleb and his new friend Abby to come
with them the children are whisked away
to an Earth-like planet without their
parents and the film ends abruptly as
you'll see again later on this list it
was aliens doesn't make for particularly
compelling twist ending there's more
questions raised than answers given but
it doesn't seem like anyone is clamoring
for answers after that disappointing
finale well what do you believe
I think it just happens
the 1978 big screen adaptation of
Superman starring Christopher Reeve is
without a shadow of a doubt a stone cold
classic and a major landmark in the
history of superhero media the Richard
Donner directed film was one of the
first to approach its source material
with both ambition and seriousness
resulting in a sincere and reverent
adaptation that opened the door for
other filmmakers to do the same working
together Donner and Reed infused the Man
of Steel with humor and Humanity telling
the type of story that Superman fans had
waited decades for for all the many
assets and accolades held by Superman
however it also comes with one massive
liability to many fans it's infamously
cheap time reversing ending like some of
the other endings on this list Superman
features an otherwise complete finale to
the film's events that's quickly rewound
and replaced with something less
satisfying rather than see Superman deal
with the emotional turmoil of losing
Lois Lane theatrical audiences were
treated to the hero literally altering
the rotation of the earth to do things
over again people could believe a man
could fly faster than a speeding bullet
and punch more powerfully than a
locomotive but reversing time was just a
bridge too far for some despite an
ending that feels disjointed and
incomplete 10 Cloverfield Lane is worth
a watch for sure the pacing in Dan
trachtenberg's intense Thriller never
lets up and maintains an unrelenting
uncomfortably tense atmosphere all the
way through after Michelle is knocked
out in a car accident she wakes up in a
strange bunker with two men she's never
met Howard the owner of the bunker tells
her that an event has occurred on the
surface that makes it uninhabitable and
that she's only safe underground as time
goes on Michelle realizes that Howard is
dangerous and if she wants a chance at
surviving she'll have to take her
chances topside she manages to barely
Escape power but when she makes her
escape and finally emerges from the
bunker it turns out that the Doomsday
prepper may not have been so crazy after
all
crazy is building your Ark After the
flood has already come
that's right it's aliens after barely
avoiding a UFO's attacks Michelle makes
her way to Houston to Aid the survivors
of the invasion and credits roll
audiences may not have been terribly
surprised by the Sci-Fi twist especially
since the original Cloverfield leaned
into it hard still a number of viewers
held out hope for something a bit more
subversive and grounded
in Spielberg's 2005 film adaptation of
War of the Worlds follows Tom Cruise as
Ray farrier a dock worker in New York
who is estranged from his daughter and
son he watches them while his ex-wife
goes out of town to visit her parents in
Boston and while she's gone things go
horribly wrong after a series of
lightning strikes disrupt the power grid
some sort of War Machine rises from the
ground and begins vaporizing people
causing mass destruction an alien
species is behind the attack and Rey is
on a mission to protect his children and
reunite them with their mother in the
end the entire family miraculously
survives and finds each other in Boston
while the aliens are suddenly killed off
by the microbes that cover every surface
on Earth as it turns out even Spielberg
agrees with fans who think the movie
wraps up a bit too easily the director
is quoted in the book James Cameron's
story of Science Fiction as saying that
film doesn't have a good ending I never
could figure out how to end that darn
thing ever since the sixth sense it
seems like most of director M Night
shyamalan's signature twist endings have
been misses rather than hits although
science is generally regarded as a
standout entry in his filmography
accepting the ending requires some
serious suspension of disbelief to be
fair it's a film about an alien invasion
so it's not like every plot Point could
be 100 plausible but there's a glaring
hole in the reason behind the alien's
demise after extraterrestrials begin
terrorizing the planet and Target his
family former Minister Graham Hess
discovers that simply splashing the
aliens with water will cause them to
react as though they've been burned
eventually killing them the aliens are
now forced to quickly flee the planet as
they realize it's inhospitable for them
there's a monster outside my room can I
have a glass of water
here's the problem the Earth is 70 water
and usually there's plenty of moisture
in the air the aliens would have been
exposed to water the moment they exited
their ships without suits does that make
signs a bad movie not necessarily but
it's ending left a lot of people feeling
like the aliens burned by H2O the ending
of David Fincher's 1997 Thriller the
game is an odd case since its release
fans and critics have voiced opposite
opinions about its Effectiveness one
side considers it unsatisfying and
invalidating while the other side
maintains the invalidation is the whole
point whether or not the ending is just
the intended final turn of the titular
gain it's almost impossible to deny that
it feels pretty cheap the plot of the
game revolves around Michael Douglas's
character Nicholas becoming embroiled in
a series of increasingly bizarre and
existentially confusing circumstances
they ultimately include Nicholas in a
live burial and a rooftop fratricide so
when it's revealed that everything was
staged no one was actually hurt and
nothing happened as Nicholas thought it
did a lot of viewers have been left left
feeling cheated even Nicholas's final
prize a shirt that says I was drugged
and left for dead in Mexico and all I
got was this stupid t-shirt can come
across like a pointed jab at everyone
who had become invested in the narrative
some people adore the ending of the game
for its boldness and absurdity but just
as many were turned off by its sudden
and dramatic shift in tone the Indiana
Jones franchise has captivated audiences
for decades it began in 1981 with
Raiders of the Lost Ark and continued
with temple of doom and Last Crusade
completing before the decade was over
nearly 20 years passed without another
sequel until Indiana Jones and the
kingdom of the Crystal Skull premiered
in 2008 an early scene in which Indy
survives an atomic explosion inside a
lead-lined fridge was the subject of hot
debate but the ending was also so
nonsensical that it felt like a
disservice to the entire franchise what
exactly am I being accused of besides
surviving a nuclear blast
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull wraps up by
waving away the entire plot with a
simple yet overdone explanation it was
aliens to top it all off after seeing a
spaceship rise from underneath an
ancient city and watching some of his
colleagues get sucked into a Vortex the
final moments essentially just show Indy
returning to normal life Indy has
witnessed some pretty wild Supernatural
happenings in his first three Adventures
but somehow this sci-fi twist feels like
something else entirely the fan
community's negative reaction to Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull is well documented
at this point whether it was the plot
armored fridge or the Extraterrestrial
surprise it seemed like most people who
saw the movie when it came out had
something to complain about
just like the 2011 film Limitless the
plot of the science fiction movie Lucy
relies on the premise that human beings
only use 10 percent of our brains this
often repeated fact is nothing more than
a myth but even if you accept it as
truth solely for the run time of the
film it still doesn't lead to a solid
conclusion the titular protagonist Lucy
is kidnapped by drug mules and ends up
ingesting an illicit substance that
gives her the ability to use more and
more of her brain as time goes on this
gives her superhuman Powers including
telepathy telekinesis and the inability
to feel pain in the final moments of the
film Lucy finally brings her cognitive
power to full capacity and she Journeys
back in time through the cosmos to the
moment of the big bang her physical body
apparently becomes a flash drive yet she
is able to send a text to a police
captain she had been working with that
simply States I am everywhere talk about
vague it's unclear as to why anyone
thought that this film would be best
wrapped up with an ambiguous bite-sized
nugget of philosophy from Lucy have you
ever seen a magician in action who was
so so skilled its sleight of hand that
for just a moment you were convinced
that magic was real that's basically the
idea behind now you see me but kicked up
more than a few notches this Infamous
film follows a group of four highly
talented illusionists called the
horsemen who perform a signature
mind-blowing trick they extract money
from wealthy people's bank accounts and
give it to audience members naturally
the authorities become suspicious of
their activities and FBI agent Dylan
Rose is on the case by the end of the
film however it's revealed that Rhodes
himself is actually an Illusionist too
oh oh my God
I did not see that coming it's
impossible
Rhodes had been working behind the
scenes as the fifth Horseman the whole
time avenging his father's death by
stealing from the people responsible the
horsemen are all invited to join a
secret society called The Eye and the
film turns from a heist Thriller to
something else entirely at the very last
second with so little Clarity over
what's real and what's merely an
illusion it's no wonder that audiences
left theaters feeling confused based on
the novel of the same name by Richard
Matheson the post-apocalyptic film I Am
Legend follows U.S army virologist
Robert Neville as he struggles to
survive each day in an eerily empty New
York City the majority of those who
remain from a lethal viral outbreak have
mutated into zombie-like creatures known
as the dark Seekers Neville spends the
majority of his time trying to find a
cure for the virus eventually capturing
a female darkseeker to experiment on
after three years with no one but his
German Shepherd to keep him company
Neville finally meets two fellow
survivors a woman named Anna and her son
Ethan from there it's not long before
the results of his tests lead him to a
cure when the dark Seekers come after
Neville for Revenge he's forced to
sacrifice himself to save Anna and Ethan
who protect the Cure and escape to a
survivor's Camp however the ending of
the director's cut follows the theme of
the novel more closely and completely
flips the perspective of the film in the
process in that version Neville
interacts with the alpha male of the
dark Seekers and returns without finding
a cure he realizes that to the dark
Seekers he has actually been the monster
all along though the theatrical cut is
not without its Defenders the only
opinion more popular than preferring the
director's cut is thinking that the
ending of Matheson's book wipes the
floor with both
the 2003 extreme French horror film high
tension really seems like it was made
twist first with a story built around it
to allow the reveal to happen as a
result its ending has become one of the
most commonly cited in online
discussions of Bad Endings even
frequently proclaimed as one of the
worst twists of all time to make a long
and excruciatingly bloody story short
the dramatic twist at the end of high
tension is that the film's slasher
killer was secretly one of the movie's
two apparent protagonists that probably
would have been fine if it didn't mean
that the previous events were physically
impossible viewers are expected to
believe that a character is able to be
in two places at once and that didn't
sit well with many regardless of how
good the preceding hour might have been
critic Maitland McDonough wrote for TV
Guide Unfortunately they squandered
their White Knuckle Goodwill on an 11th
Hour about face so Preposterous it
undermines everything that preceded it
perhaps with some more clever writing
high tension could have stuck the
landing but as it is it's earned a
pretty understandable reputation as an
illogical mess thank you in all fairness
to the cast and crew of Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker there is no single
ending that could have pleased every
single one of the franchise's millions
of fans even with that in mind however
it's hard to call the ending the
filmmakers ultimately chose anything but
cheap and unsatisfying
somehow Palpatine returned
[Music]
for a great many Star Wars enthusiasts
the ending of the rise of Skywalker was
the worst part of a Trilogy that had
already featured several objectionable
sequences but unlike the trilogy's other
alleged faults which most often offended
by ignoring characters in Canon from
Days of Star Wars past the finale
committed an even worse and even cheaper
sin it blatantly erased the overarching
story of its own Trilogy Rey being the
child of nobodies showed that anyone can
be a Jedi but episode 9 reversed that by
making her the granddaughter of one of
the franchise's most powerful bad guys
there are too many offenses to list in
the rise of Skywalker from the awkward
kiss to the fact that Palpatine is there
at all but taken all together it felt to
many fans that the ending was nothing
more than a series of Rush choices made
to drum up nostalgia Alfred Hitchcock's
the birds like the vast majority of
Hitchcock's films is an excellent piece
of Cinema with an enduring Legacy and
pervasive influence it introduced
mainstream audiences to an entirely new
brand of horror one that generates
Effectiveness by remaining vague
throughout and never explaining itself a
major component of that haunting
ambiguity is the film's ending which
consists of a mere Fade to Black after
the main character's drive away though
the birds have ceased their assault for
the moment there is no answer as to
whether or not they'll begin again only
heightening the terror while the ending
is an effective one it's also
undoubtedly a cheap one especially given
the fact that the original script
included an answer and resolution
involving a car chase which Hitchcock
simply cut film Scholars and enthusiasts
are of two minds about the ending of The
Birds either its uncertainty makes it
thoughtful and effective or it finishes
on an unsatisfactory note no one could
ever dispute that it's a memorable and
influential horror classic but the
quality of its ending is certainly Up
For Debate based on Don Winslow's novel
of the same name Oliver Stone's 2012
Thriller Savages essentially develops
into little more than worn out tropes in
the final scenes wealthy marijuana
growers Chon and Ben who were in a
polyamorous relationship with their
girlfriend Ophelia get caught up in a
violent Mexican drug cartel Ophelia is
kidnapped and held against her will to
prevent Sean and Ben from backing out of
the partnership and leaving the world of
crime as the conflicts escalate all of
the high-stakes drama culminates in a
gunfight which naturally doesn't go as
planned Ben is fatally wounded and Chon
administers a lethal injection to Ben
Ophelia and himself so that they can all
die together that's the way I am
truth has a mind of its own
of course the film ends up taking a
different turn Ophelia wakes up very
much alive revealing that the previous
scene was nothing but a nightmare as DEA
agents end up capturing some of the
high-ranking members of the cartel the
three escaped to an undisclosed tropical
island where they live on the beach so
it turns out that the stakes were pretty
low for the protagonists all along it's
no wonder that Savages never received
the same Acclaim as many of Oliver
Stone's other movies like platoon and
JFK
it's no secret that the ending to James
Cameron's 1997 historical epic Titanic
has been met with an ocean of deep dark
frigid criticism since its release what
may surprise you however is that two
entirely separate sequences in the
finale have generated Mass derision in
both for their own unique approaches of
cheapness of course the infamous Dora
scene leading to the death of Jack has
inspired an endless amount of scrutiny
but so has the emotional wrap-up
sequence in the modern day which ends
with rose dying and meeting Jack in
heaven that final moment would be
incredibly sweet if she didn't also have
a husband up there waiting for her too
as anyone who's participated in
discussions about Titanic knows though
it's the door scene that has truly
capture people's attention the question
of whether or not both lovebirds could
have fit on the floating door together
has been raised for decades even
prompting The MythBusters to test it out
for themselves in 2022 though Cameron
himself revealed that he had funded a
scientific study with a hypothermia
expert he told variety we have done a
scientific study to put this whole thing
to rest and drive a stay through its
heart once and for all foreign during
his arduous preparations for
Interstellar Christopher Nolan went to
Great Lengths to ensure the movie's
scientific accuracy the director worked
with Nobel Laureate in physics Kip
Thorne whose influence on the project
extended from its initial conception all
the way through writing and digital
effects the end result is a film deeply
rooted in the known behaviors of stars
gravity black holes and relativity until
its surreal ending a sequence that many
fans consider frustrating and cheap
after sacrificing himself by falling
into a black hole astronaut Joseph
Cooper finds himself in a
five-dimensional tesseract made by time
traveling humans from the future by
communicating with his daughter in the
past Cooper is able to save humanity and
in the process he learns that the most
powerful force in the universe is not
gravity or entropy but love love is the
one thing we're capable of perceiving
that transcends dimensions of time and
space
the heartstring tugging ending of
interstellar certainly has its Defenders
but many viewers felt annoyed that the
Sci-Fi epic didn't stay rooted in
scientific accuracy is it a beautiful
moment or a disappointing cop-out that's
up to you to decide
Guillermo del Toro's 2017 fantasy
Romance the shape of water is an
excellent movie with a solid amount of
awards and critical ratings that speak
for themselves there is simply no
deriding the Best Picture Winner as a
whole but that doesn't mean that every
one of its parts is Untouchable
throughout the film protagonist Eliza
and her amphibious lover are pursued by
the evil Colonel Strickland who intends
to dissect the creature in the name of
scientific progress however after Eliza
Is tragically shot it's the amphibian
man who slices Strickland's neck instead
killing him in a Twist of karmic Justice
many viewers expected to see Eliza die
in her Lover's arms but the actual
ending ended up being a bit more
controversial Eliza seemingly dies in
the water only to be magically
resurrected and granted gills by the
amphibian man for many the sudden and
unprecedented use of a drama
neutralizing superpower to undo previous
story beats felt like a cop-out along
the lines of Superman's time reversal so
what would have been a better finale in
her essay for high on Films writer
palavi dendamity wrote instead of the
appearance of Eliza's gills the movie
could just have ended with both of them
in the water holding on to each other it
would still be ambiguous but the
implications of that ending would be
different and far more powerful
one of the most disappointing
frustrating types of cheap movie endings
is when a film decides to end without
addressing a main theme that it spent
ample time setting up it's worse when
the theme was built up over multiple
films a Trilogy for instance and of
course it's even worse than that when
the ending directly contradicts the main
theme instead of simply ignoring it
unfortunately for many fans of
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
in their eyes that worst case scenario
is exactly what they got with the Dark
Knight Rises in order to prevent Bane's
neutron bomb from destroying Gotham
Bruce Wayne hooks it to his Airship and
flies it over the bay in his final act
as Batman he sacrifices his life to save
the people of his City at least that's
what the movie wants you to think at
first during the final scene in Florence
Italy Alfred sees Wayne alive and well
it turns out that the hero actually
faked his own death having fixed the
autopilot function in his flying machine
Wayne survival along with the attack
Dawn revealed that police officer John
Blake's legal first name is Robin felt
needless and pandering to many
Jim jarmich is known for his thoughtful
films with independent sensibilities his
takes on genre fare from the martial
arts mob flick Ghost Dog The Way of the
Samurai to the vampire romance Only
Lovers Left Alive have been met with
critical Acclaim that's why when it was
announced that darmish's next project
would be a zombie comedy with what was
called the biggest cast ever
disassembled fans of the filmmaker were
pretty hyped starring everyone from Bill
Murray and Adam Driver to Danny Glover
and Tilda Swinton the dead don't die
ended up being an entertaining opiate
slow metacomity in which a shift in the
Earth's axis has caused the deceased to
start rising out of their graves so how
did this rollicking Undead romp turned
so many people against it by the end no
it couldn't be there's no way well if
you can believe it it's aliens once
again if you're surprised to see a UFO
make an appearance in the zombie flick
you're not alone so are the main
characters who fully annihilate the
fourth wall as they remark on the
bizarre plot development was that in the
script
no
not the one I read
garmish was almost certainly satirizing
the trend of twist-ending aliens with
his film's finale but many audience
members who weren't in on the joke left
the theater with a bad taste in their
mouth
foreign